thanks very much so yeah the the title
is a slight joke though I started
writing a relatively normal title and
then I realized that had a lot of peas
in it so I thought I would add a few
more just to make it difficult for the
session chess to pronounce so sorry okay
so there's a lot to get through so I
will hurry on quite quickly but in a
moment I'm going to show you how to
build perfect Python packages from
scratch I won't be taking questions
because honestly this is like the tight
space for 30 minutes anyway but I still
have to talk about something first
that's more important than Python
packaging and that's me so my name is
not gt2k but this is my handle more or
less everywhere online feel free to
follow me on Twitter I tweet about
Python and brexit occasionally angrily
so yep my real name is Mark Smith I'm a
developer advocate for next mode one of
the conference sponsors I would be
remiss if I didn't at least briefly talk
about next mode we are a software as a
service company we offer REST API is
that allow you to do telecommunications
and various other forms of communication
including video streaming online to
mobile devices and web server your web
apps and things like that if that sounds
interesting come and talk to us at the
next Moe booth or send me a tweet or
come and talk to me around the
conference I'm happy to talk about that
another time so now I've talked about
next moment let me talk about JavaScript
so in March 2016 a developer removed a
library called left pad from NPM the
node.js equivalent of Pi P is a big web
service holds packages when you need to
pull down those packages and install
them into your JavaScript application
you run NPM and it downloads them and
installs them so that you can access
them from your program left pad so it
broke lots of packages that depended on
left pad it turns out that quite a lot
of packages on NPM depended on left pad
in fact it had been downloaded two
million four hundred and eighty six
thousand six hundred and ninety six
times in the months before it was
removed from and from the
the repository it was just one function
and it was eleven lines of code that
padded a string to a certain length by
adding characters to the start of that
string and lots of people thought that
this made the JavaScript community look
kind of silly it's why would anybody
publish a package that only consisted of
11 lines of code why would anybody use a
package that only consisted of 11 lines
of code now I don't think it made the
JavaScript community look silly I think
actually it made the JavaScript
community look pretty awesome now
obviously there's some problems with the
fact that people can remove a package
that everybody's depending on and kind
of break the entire JavaScript
community's software but in general why
was this package published so if you
don't agree that this made the
JavaScript community look awesome
and feel free to fight me on Twitter so
the left pad the left pad is not a
problem left pad was a solution
so because the JavaScript standard
library is relatively small and doesn't
contain lots of useful functions that
say the Python library standard library
does contain like the ability to left
pad a string with some characters a
developer wrote a solution for it
himself and because NPM makes it easy to
publish small items of code he did and
he made that code available to other
developers so that they then didn't have
to reinvent the wheel and that means
that we people can bug fix in one
location they can submit PRS to improve
these 11 lines of code and then
ultimately people can well ideally
depend upon it now the alternative to
this is copy and paste copy and paste I
think you can agree is not how you
should share your code because it's
really easy to share with NPM people do
and even with really small libraries and
I don't think that's really the case
with Python because people find Python
packaging slightly fiddly it's there are
some slightly odd things which we'll go
through about pushing your first Python
package to pipe I do I made it difficult
for myself to say some of these
sentences as well so people are a bit
afraid of setup py there is a good
documentation out there lots of it
conflicts with each other
but there is I think a growing movement
to bring some of this stuff together and
make it easier to find current best
practices hopefully this talk will help
a little bit so what I really want
everybody in this room to feel at the
end of this talk is confident to publish
packages to fight bi relatively small
packages
maybe ideally pure Python packages which
is what the example is going to be so I
would like you all to make a package
what we're going to do in this talk is I
am going to show you how to make a
package so the first thing the
assumption is that you already have some
code which is general enough or close to
general enough that you think it would
be useful for other people so let's take
some useful general-purpose code like a
function that prints hello world now who
in this room hasn't written this program
in some form exactly now that is totally
wasted time everybody in this room has
written this program wouldn't it be so
much better if you could pip install it
and call that code from somewhere else
so that's what we're going to do also
note there's an F string here f strings
are awesome you should use them so the
idea is you've written some code that
you're proud of you would like to share
it with the world so the first thing to
do is extract it from your code base so
that it is independent of that code base
that's your problem I'm not going to
show you how to do that in this case
we're going to extract this code into a
file called hello world py is a Python
module next we're going to put that
module in a source directory and I will
explain towards the end of the talk why
we did that for the moment just assume
henyk is excitedly clapping for the
second time today
awkward so I'll explain why later but
for the moment just just take this as
correct practice and then in the same
directory as the source directory
directly the contains our source
directory we are going to create our
setup py file you can open it up in your
favorite text editor or Python IDE and
we will enter something like this into
the file so the first thing to note here
is that we're importing from setup tools
and not to dis to tools
dist utils you will still find
documentation online that recommends
importing from disk details don't do
that it's not that powerful compared to
setup tools pip already is distributed
with setup tools so if you are
installing packages with pip you have
setup tools it's not a third-party
dependency so and then we have this
function underneath it we call setup
that we've imported from the setup tools
tools module it's a bit weird for now
just don't think of it as a function
call think of it as configuration each
of those parameters is essentially a
line of configuration that you are pass
it that you are telling you are giving
to pip to tell it how to install your
package so this is pretty much the bare
minimum setup information you need to
provide so we start with a name name is
what you pip install so this is the name
on pipe I that it will be uploaded under
so people will install it it doesn't
have to be the name of the Python code
that people with import it's a separate
thing usually they're the same sometimes
they're different we need to pick a
version number here I've just started
with zero zero one zero zero
version numbers and imply that it's
unstable there is a good chance that the
first few times you upload this to pi PI
there will be a minor packaging mistake
and so this is a good stage to start to
upload packages to pi pi while you've
still got this unstable version number
so you're not worried about kind of
breaking people seeing instability and
it's not actually your codebase it's
actually your packaging configuration
then we have a description
this is usually a one-liner at this
point say hello it's not a very useful
description but we'll leave it at that
then we have pi modules which is a list
of the actual Python code modules so we
have a file called hello world up py so
in here we're saying this is the code
that we want to distribute so that's
what people import not what they pip
install and then finally again this is a
kind of cargo copy and paste sets up
config we have this package dear line
which is a map that sort of said empty
string and source that all that is doing
is telling setup tools that our code is
under a source directory so don't worry
put it in your code and forget about it
after that so now we've we've built a
package so let's build it potentially we
could distribute it so we run the setup
file we've just created with the be
distri all commands this tells it to
create a wheeeeel file that's something
that is appropriate for uploading to pi
PI and it will spit out a load about put
most of which I've deleted from here but
the line that I've highlighted in bold
up here is the one that's important so
what that's saying is that it's just
copied our HelloWorld py code file into
the Lib directory which means that it
will end up in in our wheel if that's
not there then essentially there will be
no code in we'll have an empty an empty
wheel file and it won't work so we can
now look at what's been created as that
part of a be distilled command so here
are the directories and files so
remember we've only actually created two
files so far HelloWorld py and setup py
so everything else here it was created
by setup tools so I have a few things
here it's created an egg info directory
in our source directory you'll want to
get ignore this I'll show you how to do
that at the moment this is horrible I
wish it didn't do this I'm going to
ignore it from now on
then we have a built directory so this
is where setup tools kind of
moved our files to in the process of
building our wheel file you will see the
hello well the arrow is not in the right
place but you will see the hello world
py file in there
so again validated that our code is
actually going to be in our wheel and
then finally we've got the actual wheel
file here that it's put in our disk
directories so that is our final
distribution so now we can install it
locally so this is just effectively
testing our packaging so it's not
testing our code but it's testing our
setup py file so here we are going to
pip install and then with the - e flag
and . . dot whatever you want to call it
this can be confusing to people if you
haven't seen this before
just out of interest who hasn't seen
this before yeah i thought so
this is actually an essential command if
you are building Python packages or
rather they're essential flags so the -
e normally when you install a Python
package it installs it into your site
packages folder inside your Python
distribution it copies the code into
your Python distribution we don't really
want to do that while we're working on
our project we want it to just work with
the code that's in our source directory
so that's what - e does it essentially
links to the code that you're working on
instead of copying code into another
location
so that means we can once we've install
this package we can to continue to work
with it
continue to run it continue to write
code against it without having these two
copies of our code that is just going to
cause us problems further down the line
the full stop at the end means install
the package in the current directory so
it's looking at the setup py file and so
it's saying install this package by
linking to the code that I'm working on
will you run this every so often every
time you change your setup your Wi-Fi
you essentially run this again to make
sure that your package is installing
correctly and that your your Python code
is available to you so bear in mind our
code is under a source directory at the
moment so if we run Python in that
current directory we can't import hello
world yet because it's not in our path
so let's in theory let's test it so here
we run Python the repple and then we do
our from hello world import say hello
because we've just installed our code
into our car
virtual environments we kept this will
work now even though our code is on to
the source directory Python has been
told where our code is by the setup py
file so we can execute the say hello
function we can execute it by passing at
the optional parameter everything works
as we would hope so that's it's a rough
testing we'll get on to better testing
at a moment but there's just just a
confirmation that our code is installing
correctly so at this point we have a
working package with some useful code in
it so we could upload that to pi pi
immediately but I would say that there's
a few things that we really need to do
before we get to that point that's
documentation and testing but also just
a little bit of housekeeping which I'll
run through now so as I said there's
some files created that you really don't
want to add to your git repository so
it's useful to have to get ignore file
this website is fantastic they make it
easy to get a hold of github
standard get ignore files that they
publish for different language and
operating system communities so you
would write Python in that text box hit
create and it will just spit out a text
file into the web browser that you can
copy and paste into a dot git ignore
file so now we're ignoring all the main
files that Python creates so it will
stop you from uploading pyc files and a
bunch of other artifacts on the Python
project if we're going to publish this
code we also need a license if we don't
have a license we haven't given
permission to people permission to run
our code they can look at it but they
can't copy it or use it which is not
greatly useful so we need a license dot
txt file and a good way to if you if you
don't know the ins and outs of the
different licenses and the restrictions
and freedoms they grant the software
that you're publishing this website
choose a license com is incredibly
useful
it essentially asks you lots of
questions and then gives you your
options and how they compare to each
other so it's a good way it's a human
way for non legal people to understand
the differences between different
software licenses we need to add some
classifiers to our setup py file so that
people can find the project in pi pi by
searching on our filtering on Common
Criteria
so here we say that this is Python 3
code it runs under Python 3.6 and 3.7 we
haven't really tested that yet but but
we know that there only runs under those
versions of Python because where there's
an F string in the codes like
doubt I chose the gplv2 so put that in
there that was a bit of an arbitrary
choice these cannot be looked up in this
URL at the bottom ypi dogs classify it
classifies there's a bunch of them try
and be as try and apply all the useful
classifiers to your project so that
you're describing what this project is
for and how it's used then you need some
documentation but before you write some
documentation you need to work out what
format you're going to write your
documentation and you basically have two
choices at the moment one is
restructured text which is written in
Python it's used widely in the Python
community all over the place and core
documentation is written in it a whole
bunch of the libraries you use have
written in restructured text but it is a
Python solution and if you're working on
a project that has some Python code and
maybe some rust code or some C code or
something like that those people will
will probably not have encountered
restructure text before but they will
probably have encountered markdown and
markdown is a valid choice it is simpler
but also less powerful so you really
choose you're making some compromises
here both of them allow you to use tools
like Sphinx for restructure text or make
ducts for markdown to compile a
directory of markdown or rest files into
a directory of documentation that's all
linked together and both of these are
supported by read the docs so you can
publish either of these documentation
kind of sites to read the docs and then
not have to worry about hosting them
yourself
so once we've decided and I've chosen
markdown again kind of arbitrarily we
need to write a readme that's pretty
much essential for any modern project
here we have a title the title of the
project we have a small paragraph
describing what the project does we
should have a section describing how to
install the projects with some sample
command line code for installer for pip
installing this project we should have
some sample code just to tell people how
to use the useful code that we publish
to pi pi and then once we've written
this it's nice to have this also
published on pi PI so as well as
publishing on say github or get lab or
wherever you're publishing your code it
would be really nice if we could insert
make this essentially the official
description of our project and we can do
that
this again this is even if you've
published packages before and you use
restructured text to write you'll read
me this is now a new feature in pi pi as
of about a year ago pi pi supports
markdown directly so you don't need to
convert your markdown to restructure
text before pushing it up to PI pi
so here I've just got we're taking
advantage of the fact that sets up
people why file is code and not
configuration by opening the readme file
reading in this this block of markdown
and then we apply that string to our
setup call so we use the long
description parameter just provide this
this string value that we put into a
variable and then very importantly we
need to tell pi PI this is marked down
and not restructured text which we do by
providing this mime type as this content
type parameter at the end I wanted to
talk about dependencies I've cut this
talk down a bit so we won't actually
show any code that uses blessings but
for example if we used this terminal
coloring library called blessings this
is how we would add it to our setup py
file so we have it an install requires
parameter it's a list of these
specifiers that describe the library and
the versions we're prepared to accept I
will talk a little bit more about those
in a moment if we change the library
dependencies or anything else as I said
we should run our pip install - II dr
command again just to reinstall the
package and just make sure it actually
pulls down the dependencies and at least
things work together and then we should
run some tests but we don't have tests
and we shouldn't just keep on opening up
the repple and randomly calling
functions to make sure that things work
I would recommend you write your tests
with PI test PI test it's awesome but in
order to write tests with quite s again
we need more dependencies but this time
we're not talking about dependency of
our library like blessings so we're not
saying this is how this is needed to run
we're we're saying this is a development
dependency so this is something people
need to install in order to develop code
with our library and in order to declare
to develop dev dependencies I recommend
you add them as extras into your setup
py but a lot of people here I suspect
are using requirements dot txt for this
if you have a setup py file I would
argue you do not need a requirements txt
you can do all of this within quite
under standard packaging framework and
you get some advantages because again
this is code
not configuration extra so the way this
works it looks a little bit like install
requires but it's got an extra layer of
indirection so you'll see that it's a
it's a dictionary rather than a list
it's a but but you still see that list
in there is the first value so the key
is the name of your extra so in this
case we're saying dev and we will tell
people that they need to install the dev
extras in order to work with our project
and then after that it is just a list of
dependencies so in this case we're
setting PI tests above or equal to the
value of 3.2 version 3.7 and then we can
tell people how to use it so again we
update the readme we have a section
saying if you would like to help develop
hello world this is how you install the
development dependencies so that you can
run the tests and it looks very similar
to before but you'll see we have the
word dev in square brackets afterwards
it's saying we're installing our current
module with the dev extras you may have
used this with other packages maybe not
seen how that was specified I stole this
straight from adders which i think is
why Teaneck is here so yes if we if we
install the extras you will see that it
installs a whole bunch of other stuff
basically dependencies for quite us so
the difference between install requires
and extras requires is that install
requires is for production dependencies
things like flask click numpy pandas and
the version should be as relaxed as they
possibly can be so you should be testing
against multiple versions of each
dependency in this way you're not
locking your users in to a specific
version of a shared dependency so if
both you and your user are using a ters
ideally you need an overlap there so if
you're all using if you're using version
3 they use in 3rd and 4 you know they're
not gonna be able to use your package
unless they make some changes
extras require is different it's for
optional requirements for development or
testing or whatever extras you what
groups of extras you want to create and
the version should be in my opinion as
specific as possible because you're
you're trying to get your your
developers up and running as quickly as
possible and so creating an identical
environment to yours and the other
developers who have been working with
the code is that's just going to make
everybody's life easier rather than
trying to debug like minor variations in
your develop
penances requirements dot txt still has
a place but I would argue it's for apps
that you deploy onto machines that you
control so in this case you're pinning
every single production requirement to a
specific version so that you're
producing a well-tested
collection of code on a on a destination
machine so use fixed version numbers
with the double equals operator and you
use pip freeze to just spit out all of
the things that are currently installed
and straight to your requirements dot
txt so here we write some tests I'm
going to zoom through this a bit because
I'm running slowly slower than I would
like so but yes we run run our code now
we just need to run my test to actually
test our code each time it's much easier
than actually executing the code by hand
it will spit out a bunch of stuff to say
what it's version of Python you're using
and things like that and then it will
spit up hope in hopefully that your
tests passed so now what we've done so
far this is this is what we've produced
we've got a license file a readme file a
setup file source directory with our
code and a test you can obviously stick
your tests in the test directory if you
have more than test files it's good to
distribute source just distributions as
well as binary distributions for various
reasons people can check the code before
they run it they may not have access to
github to access the code they may just
need to verify the code before they run
it when you run s test against our setup
py file we actually get some warnings
saying it would like some more data for
some reason s test would really like to
know the maintainer and maintainer email
or the author and/or email so it's told
us that so we can just add those in
that's three lines we have the URL of
the project linked to github in this
case my name and my email address excuse
me so now we need to test that make sure
that source distribution contains all
the files we want it to so it just when
you run s test it just creates an in
this case of gzip tar ball and we can
use the tar command to unzip that and
have a look at the stuff inside and when
we have a look at it we noticed it
hasn't got our license txt file or our
test hello world file ideally a source
distribution could contain everything
that is in this snapshot of code so
everything we're distributing everything
that gets built into the binary
distribution
in order to add those missing files into
our source distribution we need to write
a manifest input file
they are fiddly and annoying fortunately
there's a tool called check manifest
that does pretty much all of this for us
or at least we'll get us started quickly
so you can pip install that you can add
it to your development dependencies if
you like you run it for the first time
with this create flag and then it will
create your manifest I am I recommend
having a look at it it's just things
like includes and excludes lines for
various files that it's found in the
project that it tries to make sure that
everything you have in get ends up in
your sauce distribution so it's finding
these files and adding them to the
manifest input file so then if we build
our source distribution again we can
unzip it and then we see that now just
out of the box the check manifest has
created a manifest file that includes
the files that were missing so now let's
publish it it's good to publish earlier
rather than later if you try to perfect
everything you will really never publish
the package so as soon as the point you
have something useful not necessarily
perfect try and get it up apart from
anything else it will register your
package name on PI pi to your project so
you're not letting somebody else just
kind of come in in the months while
you're working on your project you used
to be able to register your project
before you uploaded code now you need to
actually upload the code in order to
register a name so here we run a setup
py with the be distri land the s disk
command - and in our district tree will
now have a wheel file and our source
distribution in order to push the PI PR
you need to use twine for various
reasons it separates the build step from
the upload step which means that you can
do these manual checks of your of your
distribution files before you upload to
pi PI otherwise it's a single command to
kind of build and push up your code if
you get it wrong it's going to mess
things up for you so here we install
twine we use the twine upload to command
it also uses HTTP whereas for a while
pip didn't so
it's safer sorry setup stools didn't if
you get to play P I the website quickly
enough you will see the name of your
project on the home page as the most
recently updated package and that's kind
of cool if you click on it you will then
get to the project page you can see our
readme file is essentially duplicated
here there's a github link that I've
just cut off at the bottom I had to
change the name of the project by the
way because there is a HelloWorld
package on pipey ie some obviously
somebody has done that so there's still
some more stuff that we need to do I
would recommend using toxin running out
of time so I apologize for running
through these I recommend using tox for
testing against different distributions
of Python and different versions of the
libraries that you depend on here we're
just testing its Python 3.6 3.7 you
installed tox you have that toxic
configuration file you it spits out
loads of output when you run tox and
hopefully at the end you get for each
one of your targets you get a command
succeeded and a little smiley face at
the end which I always think it's rather
lovely here's why we use the source
directory so root directory is the
directory we have I've been working in
if our code was in this directory if we
import hello world while running the
tests it will run the code in our source
directory sorry in our current directory
but we don't want it to do that we want
it to test
installing the package and using the
code from there by having a source
directory you are forcing it to use the
version that was just installed into the
virtual environment you should also
build on test machine on clean machines
in the past I've used Travis for this I
am probably moving my stuff to as your
pipelines and depending on when it gets
his stuff stabilized yes I won't talk
about that any more for extra credit you
can add badges to your readme for code
coverage for quality metrics you can
manage versions with bump version that's
quite nice you can test on different
operating systems you can write more
documentation you can always write more
documentation and tests you can add a
contributed section to your readme you
can implement the code of conduct and
that there's there's lots that you can
do but I recommend that you don't do any
of the stuff that I've described
the stock so there's a project called
cookie cutter that generates sets of
files from templates and people have
already created template projects for pi
PI for Python projects so if you install
cookie cutter and then you run this
command to download yol's it's there's a
few of them out there I quite like
youngins it's similar to my own way of
thinking of these things this cookie
cutter library it will then it will
download the template from github it
will ask you lots of questions because
it's much more flexible than all the
I've given you one option for each step
he offers you lots of options different
testing libraries and things like that
and then at the end of it you're done in
theory you will probably have to go and
tweak some of these files because they
won't be quite the way you want but it
took me five minutes to get up and
running using this process and then it
created all of this so you will
recognize some of the stuff in here from
the tutorial we've been through there is
extra stuff in there there is a Sphynx
directory of documentation and with just
boilerplate documentation in there at
the moment but just waiting for you to
fill it out you copy and in your code
and then you're done so that took me
about five minutes could have cut this
talk down to the last two slides if I'd
wanted instead of wasting all of your
time for half an hour but hopefully give
this gives you an overview of good
packaging practice and all the things
that you need to do to kind of build a
well-rounded package there's obviously
different directions you can move in but
this is a really good core understanding
of the things you should do for a
professionally released package and
there are other projects for
distributing libraries these days
they're very interesting that don't you
set up py or use it in different ways I
would really recommend having a look at
them if you're struggling with setup py
poetry is getting a lot of mindshare at
the moment I haven't really used them so
I can't really recommend them I'm trying
to push current most common best
practice if you are interested in the
slides or the code for this talk they
are available on this bitly link follow
me on twitter if you have any questions
feel free to grab me at the conference
come to the next mo booth tweet at me
preferably not abuse
but thank you very much for coming to my
talk
[Applause]